week one you were to stand down favorite
it's very difficult to do to go through
the whole season and come out on top I
mean congratulations battalion how does
it feel that it's officially over and
you're holding in your hands it's really
surreal to be honest I feel like we both
put so much work and so much love and
then this whole season and into every
dance that we did and we both really put
everything that we had on the floor and
to be able to be validated for that
feels amazing we see you know obviously
the physical journey that the dancing
but talking about the emotional journey
from the beginning of this season the
end is it seemed like it was a very
emotional season it definitely was I
feel like I'm a completely different
person than when I started and I know
that I'm a better person for all of this
and I'm just I'm happy to be here I'm so
happy that i took this journey and then
I got to go on it with him and that we
get to stand here together and hold this
you said many times that this was you
know the most incredible experience if
you're like what is it about Dancing
with the Stars that makes it such you
know powerful experience I don't think
that there's any other scenario really
in the world that's like this where
you're put into a situation where you
are dancing with someone who's been
doing it their entire lives and
every week you're put in a crazy
scenario but you have to step up and I
think it really shows and reveals what
kind of person you are you it's it's the
honesty that we have about being behind
the camera and the rehearsals and all of
it it's just you have to really be ready
to lay yourself on the floor where you
gonna keep the mirror ball trophy vomit
look yeah what's up by my bed by your
gun oh wait you think you're gonna have
to like you know fight your parents off
you they're gonna want to try and like
uh take it from I doubt it no no
you